ah-ah-ah dab dab on them here stab on
them haters dab on them haters hey how's
it going bros my name is Jake I'm a I'm
a Jake polar now me and Jake full
disclosure have talked in the DMS we are
French snap okay for for real I did I
did speak to you Jake after I did my
videos the first one and he seemed like
an all right dude like talking to him I
was like all right well this this guy's
not so bad but now the world seemed to
be after my man Jake Paul Jacquet and
I'm not okay with it cuz I'm a Jake
polar damn it okay you guys don't
understand the dab on the desk you sure
I'm sure you guys know all the stuff
that's going on for some reason it's
said what everyone's talking about
personally I couldn't care less okay I'd
rather learn how to say the name of all
the pokémons backwards and what their
mother's and father's name was and their
ancestry okay I'd rather memorize all
that [ __ ] but for some reason I know all
this [ __ ] that's going on I have found
something that will shock you okay we're
gonna get there but first in case you
don't know what's going on I need to
fill you guys in my man JP he's a
prankster he's a he's an absolute savage
he plays crazy pranks on the people in
his house the people in his life and
that that's just savage and if you don't
like it you can dab away I swear to God
you don't want to no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no don't do it to Nick
Crompton my bank I do I'm the only
person I love more than Jake is Nick
Jake Polish I never been a [ __ ] he died
he died everyone okay let's get to the
point there's been this news report that
came out about Jake I'm sure you've seen
it in case you haven't let's watch
tonight residents in a West Hollywood
neighborhood are angry they say they've
had enough of the chaos created by a
social media star known for his crazy
antics that man Jake Paul has a has
eight and a half million followers on
YouTube as neighbors though say that
he's been filming dangerous stunts and
he's putting people in danger Chris wolf
is live in West Hollywood tonight with a
story you will see only here on 5 Chris
that's right Rick and M B he is a social
media mega see he's a sociopath he runs
a large house in an upscale West
Hollywood neighborhood and this
tight-knit community has become the new
setting how is he not kicked wait he's
rent safe he rents the house how is he
not kicked out how I got kicked out for
being loud for like five minutes twice
I've been kicked out three times how old
are you doing with Jake
see that's my man Jake he knows how to
not get kicked out I'm not on that labor
hood and this tight-knit community has
become the new setting for many of his
pranks and performances the neighbors
hate me
why does he talk like that he apparently
makes his address no secret and that
piece of information draws an endless
stream of fans mostly young girls the
day we visited and their parents to the
property he's funny
that word just got completely it died
along with that girl
a recent stunt involved tossing
furniture into an empty pool and setting
the pile on fire
neighbors say flames eventually grew
higher than the house and as the pit was
burning and how kicked out I don't want
it I don't want it to get kicked out but
how we the [ __ ] is he not kicked out
Jesus Christ
you may we used to be a really nice
quiet street and now we're just this
like war zone where families here and
we're more than happy to have now live
here if they're respectful of their
neighbors but they're not but as
neighbors living with this everyday work
that up do they live there every day bro
you've created a living hell out here
that's like a circus yeah what do you
say to the neighbors oh that are upset
they're really upset no I honestly no
I'm honest it yeah it's terrible it's a
bad situation no I feel bad for them for
sure there's nothing we could do though
the Jake Pollard's are the strongest
army out there Debbie hurts and I feel
like I'm getting sick again it's come
back oh there's there's no way this is
no way you can get worse than that I
have one question for you yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't know how to respond to this this
is so I I'm so overwhelmed with the
cringe it's like the meme but that was
dead before it even began hey I remember
first hearing it I'm like oh that's a
joke okay that's cool
I guess he didn't like my shoes but so
so after this news media thing came out
Jake poll decides to do the noble thing
and apologize to his neighbors but you
can't film people in Los Angeles without
their consent it's a it's it's very
strict rules around there I'm sure Jake
them know but at the same time neighbors
files eavesdropping complaint against
Jake Paul says Jake P secretly recorded
conversation during apology so there's
clearly this whole thing going on
between the neighbors they don't like
him
Jake Paul is just dabbing on them then
the unthinkable happened
ten bucks got destroyed on the freeway
and here's Jake Paul's response
one of the neighbors comes over and
unscrews the screws in the tire to our
team ten vans the neighbors tried to
kill us bro they take the nuts out max
and the Martinez twins are driving down
the road and the highway all of a sudden
they hear our noise they're like what is
this thing outside the nuts are off of
the tire so they start driving slow on
the highway literally that whole entire
tire falls off and they like the bus lop
sides they go flying in the middle of
the traffic on the 101 the whole highway
stops super dangerous situation and our
neighbors are the ones that did this our
neighbors tried to kill us and and what
do we do we just make videos for kids on
the internet like who's the bad guy here
Jake you do realize that this is
potential homicide
you know they if they actually try to
kill you you need to call the cops
it's a it's not a meme after that like
you can't
you can't they can if someone takes the
screws out of your tires you have either
that's potential murder I know people
gone to jail for murder for doing that
you can't just get away you do that's is
not vagan material anymore that's some
serious [ __ ] [ __ ] if that's true but
I have some evidence to speak
differently Jake I need to look after
you I can't hold this information back
any longer
now I know you have some drama with your
brother Logan Paul Jake Paul posted this
picture of Logan Paul when he was
younger when he went through an emo face
Logan Paul shaking Leigh angry made a
diss track as a response where he made
out with Jake Paul's ex-girlfriend let's
watch
I don't know what's worse the fact that
he did it or the fact that he thinks
it's cool like I know there's a whole
bro code or whatever you're not supposed
to go with the same girl that your guy I
never gave a [ __ ] about that I think
it's stupid like who gives a [ __ ] but
it's his brother okay and the fact that
he thinks it's cool to get his
ex-girlfriend and fake kiss on a music
video that's almost as bad as as kissing
the same girl as your dad like who the
[ __ ] would do that last but certainly
not least contestant number three step
on know who's the best kisser down to
one last thing the vote so I know it's
probably a very tough decision those all
oh great it's a hard decision oh can you
imagine kissing the same girl as your
dad like this is so [ __ ] weird this
is so weird
oh my god
it's [ __ ] weird I don't can you be
imagine being the dad [ __ ] man
I don't sorry let's go back to the track
okay their car got crashed okay
the neighbors try and kill him and what
was but no one is paying attention to
logan paul's response let's watch Jake's
neighbors you guys should egg his house
or take the lug nuts off the wheels of
his cars go back on that one what do you
say or take the lug nuts off the wheels
of his cars take the lug nuts out of the
wheels of his car take the lug nuts out
of the wheels of his car he should take
the neighbors the neighbors should do it
or take the lug nuts off the wheels of
his car again or take the lug nuts off
the wheels of his car or take the lug
nuts off the wheels of his car ha ha ha
ha Jake but your brother is trying to
kill you
there's something fishy here ok Logan
Paul try to kill his brother I have
solid evidence right here that's very
interesting there's so many people who
twist and turn things to make other
people look bad in the media that's
goddamn right JP fake news media what is
this timeline Jake Paul is talking about
fake news Jake Poe isn't all right it
has been confirmed he's talking about
fake news and if you're not convinced
yet keep watch double check the rumors
only witness the facts the Jake
Pollard's are going up into the right up
into the right the right up and he's
going up into the jig Paul confirmed
natural I knew it I knew it my man JP
confirmed not see and if you don't think
so yet Jake Paul exes
Disney Channel's Buzard work midseason
Jake Paul got fired from this deck
Jake Paul I never thought I'd say these
words welcome to the family come here
buddy come to Daddy
yeah boy I'm proud of you son I'm
goddamn proud of you boy